This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Like many teens in the 80s, my first job was at the mall. I was 14, I lied about my age, I was a bus boy in an Applebee style restaurant that no longer exists. On Saturdays, I often worked three shifts in row, so I witnessed the entire circadian rhythm of the mall. At 8 o'clock I'd clean windows as the senior citizens and tracksuits powered through the empty halls, passing by shops with the cage doors still rolled down. By midday the families took over, and my usual job of cleaning glasses and plates involved cleaning up piles of foods filled on the floor.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。和 80 年代许多青少年一样，我的第一份工作也是在购物中心。那时我 14 岁，谎报了年龄，在一家如今已经不存在的苹果蜂（Applebee's）风格餐厅当杂工。每到星期六，我经常连续干三个班，所以我见证了购物中心一整天的作息规律。八点钟的时候，我会一边擦窗户，一边看着老年人和身穿运动服的人们在空旷的走廊里健步如走，从卷帘门还没拉上去的店铺旁经过。到了中午，家庭成了这里的主角，我平时清洁杯盘的工作就变成了清理地板上堆积如山的食物残渣。
By evening, the teens arrived. They couldn't afford the restaurant, but I could see them in packs congregating by the fountain, always ready with an unkind word for some act of cruelty. The mall felt terrible, I hated it. But despite this, on days when I wasn't working, I had my mom drop me off at the mall. Kids in small towns and suburbs play the hand their dealt, and being able to walk around on your own, maybe buying a cassette tape of the Smith's live album at Sam Goodey is the best that life has to offer.
到了晚上，青少年们蜂拥而至。他们消费不起那家餐厅，但我能看到他们三五成群地聚集在喷泉旁，随时准备对某些残忍的行为吐出刻薄的话语。购物中心感觉糟透了，我讨厌它。但尽管如此，在我不用上班的日子里，我还是会让妈妈把我送到购物中心。小镇和郊区的孩子只能接受命运的安排，能一个人到处走走，说不定还能在萨姆·古迪（Sam Goodey）买一盘史密斯乐队（The Smiths）现场专辑的磁带，这就是生活所能提供的最好的东西了。
I was not a very cool teen. Larry, just say, I was a very nerdy teen. This is cool adult in front of the show, Alexander Lang. I feel like there are a lot of teenage mall scenarios that I did not participate in. Like I did not like meet my first bow at the mall. I did not like stroll around with shopping bags, showing off at the mall. None of that. But no teen in the 80s could completely avoid the gravitational pull of the mall. Alexandra is the author of a new book
我可不是什么很酷的青少年。拉尔夫，直说吧，我曾经是个十足的书呆子少年。坐在节目台前这位很酷的成年人名叫亚历山大·朗。我觉得有很多青少年在购物中心经历的场景我都从未参与过。比如我没有在购物中心遇到我的初恋。我没有提着购物袋在购物中心闲逛炫耀。这些都没有。但 80 年代的任何一个青少年都无法完全摆脱购物中心的引力。亚历山大是一本新书的作者……
called Meet Me by the Found. I think part of the whole argument of this book is really that people are social creatures and that the mall had to be created because the suburbs didn't really initially think about a space for people to come together. Even though we're past the heyday of the mall, Alexandra says we haven't seen the death
这本书名叫《在喷泉旁与我相遇》。我认为这本书的核心论点之一其实是，人类是社会性动物，购物中心之所以必须被创造出来，是因为郊区在最初规划时，并没有真正为人们聚在一起的空间留出位置。尽管我们已经度过了购物中心的鼎盛时期，但亚历山大表示，我们还没有看到购物中心的消亡，即使经历了两年半的全球大流行之后也是如此。
of the mall, even after two and a half years of a global pandemic. I think that people are people and they're going to want to go back out and get together again. I think we've seen that in like the tremendous use of parks during the pandemic. And when we can safely gather indoors, like people are gonna be excited to do that because who wants to go to a park in December.
我认为人就是人，他们总是会想要重新走出去并再次聚在一起。我想我们在大流行期间对公园的大量使用中已经看到了这一点。而且当我们能够安全地在室内聚集时，人们会为此感到兴奋，因为谁会想在十二月去公园呢。
We're gonna talk about how the mall became a ubiquitous part of American culture and what's happening today as malls across the country start to disappear. Okay, so let's get down to some basics. What is a mall? What makes something a mall versus other shopping centers that existed before or after? Well, a shopping center is outdoors and a mall is indoors. That's the most basic thing. A shopping center is a strip mall or a line of stores facing the parking lot
我们来聊聊购物中心是如何成为美国文化中无处不在的一部分的，以及随着全国各地的购物中心开始消失，今天正发生着什么。好吧，让我们从一些基础知识开始。什么叫购物中心？是什么让某种东西成为购物中心，而不是以前或以后存在的其他商业中心？嗯，商业中心是露天的，而购物中心是室内的。这是最根本的区别。商业中心是一个个露天商铺，或者是一排面朝停车场的店铺……
with some sort of like covering over the space in front of them. Whereas a mall is indoors. And the earliest malls were basically just like two shopping strips put together. So you had a department store at each end, and then two lines of shops facing each other, and a covered, you know, central aisle that usually had fountains and plants and benches
前面某种程度上带有遮阳篷。而购物中心是在室内的。最早的购物中心基本上就是把两个商业街区拼在了一起。所以你两端各有一家百货公司，然后是两排相对的店铺，中间有一条带屋顶的中央过道，通常有喷泉、植物和长椅……
and other amenities. So they were really just that super simple, kind of eye-shaped plan. And this shape, the long hallway, is where the word mall comes from. That's right. Yeah. Basically, the name mall comes from Paul Mall in London, which is a narrow street where they used to play a kind of bowling game. So it was this long narrow outdoor space where people would come together to play. And so the mall from Paul Mall turned into a landscape term for that kind of long narrow green space.
以及其他配套设施。所以它们实际上就是那种超级简单、有点像眼睛形状的平面设计。这种形状，也就是长长的走廊，正是“mall”这个词的来源。没错。是的。基本上，“mall”这个名字源于伦敦的派尔迈尔街（Pall Mall），那是一条狭窄的街道，人们过去常在那里玩一种类似保龄球的游戏。所以它是一个长而窄的户外空间，人们会聚在那里游玩。因此，从派尔迈尔街（Pall Mall）演变而来的“mall”就成了一个景观术语，指代那种长而窄的绿地。
So then when you enclose that long narrow space under a roof, it is another kind of mall. So the mall in Washington is also a mall from the same origin, even though we don't really think about a shopping mall and the mall in Washington and in the same mental place. Right. That place with the reflecting pool and the Lincoln on one side. That's the capital mall. Right. But we don't. Yeah. Lincoln is the anchor store of the National Mall. He's the Macy's, the capital mall. So Victor Groen is credited as the father of the national mom. He's the maize, the capital mom. So Victor Groen is credited as the father of the mall. What was he trying to do?
所以，当你把那个长而窄的空间用屋顶围起来时，它就成了另一种“mall”。因此，华盛顿的那个国家广场（National Mall）也是源于相同词源的“mall”，尽管我们并不真的把购物中心和华盛顿的那个国家广场在脑海中归为同一类地方。没错。就是那个有倒影池、一边供奉着林肯的地方。那是国会山广场。没错。但我们不这么想。是的。林肯是国家广场的主力店。他是梅西百货，国会广场。所以维克托·格鲁恩（Victor Gruen）被誉为“购物中心之父”。他到底在尝试做什么？
What was he trying to make? So Groen was an emigre from Austria fled the Nazis to the US in the late 1930s. And he had really strong memories of the kind of charming streets of Vienna, where there are cafes and people gathered, fountains, and there's this whole rich outdoor life. So he came to America, he initially designed these very glamorous stores in Manhattan, and then he was taken up by some department store executives who were like moved to California,
他当时究竟想建造什么？所以，格鲁恩是一位来自奥地利的移民，他在 20 世纪 30 年代末为逃避纳粹逃往美国。他对维也纳迷人的街道有着非常深刻的记忆，那里有咖啡馆、人们聚集在一起的喷泉，还有丰富多彩的户外生活。因此他来到美国，最初在曼哈顿设计了那些非常迷人的店铺，然后他被一些百货公司高管看中，他们对他说：“搬到加利福尼亚去……
design our department stores. So he started designing these free standing department stores and he just felt kind of crushed by the landscape around those department stores because you could go to the store and you could park and you could go in, but then you couldn't do anything else. Like you couldn't leave and sit at a cafe. There was nowhere to meet your friends. There was none of the kind of fabric of the city that he found in European cities. So in the early 1940s,
来为我们的百货公司做设计吧。”于是他开始设计这些独立的百货公司，但他对百货公司周围的景观感到一种压抑，因为你可以开车去商店，可以停车，可以进去，但除此之外你什么也做不了。比如你不能离开并坐在咖啡馆里。没有地方可以跟朋友见面。完全没有他在欧洲城市里找到的那种城市肌理。所以在 20 世纪 40 年代初……
Grewin was living in New York and flying back and forth across the country a lot, like major, major airplane miles. And he gets stuck in Detroit on a cross-country flight because of fog. And he thinks, oh, okay, like, I'm not gonna waste this time, I have on the ground in Detroit. You know, it's like he asked his friends,
格鲁恩当时住在纽约，经常坐飞机在全国各地飞来飞去，攒下了惊人的飞行里程。由于大雾，他在一次跨国飞行中被困在了底特律。他想，噢，好吧，我可不能浪费我在底特律停留的时间。你知道的，就像他问他的朋友们……
where is life happening in Detroit? And they said, oh, it's all out in the suburbs. Okay. So he gets driven around the suburbs and he finds what he's been finding elsewhere in the US. That yes, there are all these new houses and yes, there are all these strip malls, but there's nowhere to go. And he thinks that he, you know, master salesman, he should be able to sell jailheds in
底特律最有生活气息的地方在哪里？他们说，噢，都在郊区。好吧。于是他坐着车在郊区转悠，发现了他在美国其他地方也看到过的情况。那就是，是的，这里有所有这些新房子；是的，这里有所有这些露天购物广场，但根本没地方可去。他认为自己——作为一个超级推销员——应该能够说服……
on the idea of building a branch department store and a shopping center in the suburbs. And over the next several years, he does this. He actually sells them on the idea of building four of them, Northland, Southland, Eastland, and Westland. Yeah, I've always wondered about that. Like, why do so many malls have cardinal directions in the name, no matter what city you're in, they're all like Westfield or Southport. Why is that? This is the origin story. And this is one way in which I know,
人们接受在郊区建造分店百货公司和商业中心的想法。在接下来的几年里，他真的做到了。他实际上说服他们建造了四个这样的中心：北地（Northland）、南地（Southland）、东地（Eastland）和西地（Westland）。是的，我一直很好奇这件事。为什么不管你在哪个城市，这么多购物中心的名字里都有方位词，它们都叫韦斯特菲尔德（Westfield）或是绍斯波特（Southport）之类的？这是为什么？这就是起源故事。这也是我知道的一种方式……
like the book can be slightly confusing because all the malls sound the same and it's like, yeah, that was on purpose. Because the, you know, if you're thinking about your city with the center point downtown, all of these malls wanted to establish where they were in relation to that center point. So if you were driving north on the kind of main highway out of town, you would encounter Northland or North Park or North Field or North Dale or one of these other things, you know, same with South Easter West. So all of them are like named out for their cardinal points so that people know kind of where to find them in relation to downtown.
就像这本书可能稍微有点让人困惑，因为所有的购物中心听起来都一样，而事实是：是的，那是故意的。因为，如果你以市中心为中心点来构想你的城市，所有这些购物中心都想确立它们相对于这个中心点的位置。所以如果你沿着城里主要的高速公路向北开，你就会遇到北地（Northland）、北园（North Park）、北菲尔德（North Field）、北代尔（North Dale）或者诸如此类的地方，东、南、西也是一样。所以它们全都以方位词命名，好让人们知道相对于市中心该在哪里找到它们。
And then the second part of the word is gate because it's an entry to the city, it's land because that was open land before, it's park because they're attaching it to a parkway. Like they have kind of, you know, vague geographical associations. The problem really comes that like, I grew up going to Northgate Mall in Durham, North Carolina,
然后名字的第二部分是“gate（门）”，因为它是通往城市的入口；是“land（地）”，因为这以前是开阔的土地；是“park（园）”，因为它们把商业中心依附在景观大道（parkway）旁。它们都有某种，你知道的，模糊的地理关联。真正的问题在于，我是在北卡罗来纳州达勒姆的北门购物中心（Northgate Mall）长大的……
but there's a much more famous Northgate Mall in Seattle that was one of the first malls. And it's like, so you always have to specify, you know, which city you're talking about. Yeah. And it feels like there's a certain point where the naming convention becomes just a meaningless convention like one of the fancier malls
但在西雅图有一个更著名的北门购物中心，它是最早的购物中心之一。所以你总是必须指明你到底在说哪个城市。是的。而且感觉在某个时刻，这种命名惯例变得毫无意义，就像旧金山市中心一个比较高档的购物中心……
in downtown San Francisco is called Westfield. I don't think it's West of anything or a field at all, but maybe that's just, I don't know, maybe you know. No, no, Westfield is actually a huge mall conglomerate that's now owned by Australians. But Westfield may be originally named after a Westfield that was in some town. So, Groen designed these malls in Michigan. And he saw the early mall as more of a mixed-use hub. There were shops and apartment stores, but also post offices, doctors offices. How long did that idea of a mall last?
名叫韦斯特菲尔德（Westfield）。我觉得它既不位于什么地方的西边，也根本不是什么田野，但也许这只是……我不知道，也许你知道。不，不，韦斯特菲尔德实际上是一个庞大的购物中心财团，现在由澳大利亚人拥有。但韦斯特菲尔德最初可能是以某个小镇里的韦斯特菲尔德命名的。所以，格鲁恩在密歇根州设计了这些购物中心。他将早期的购物中心视为一个多功能的综合枢纽。这里有商店和百货公司，还有邮局、诊所。这种购物中心的理念持续了多久？
Yeah. Groen definitely saw the malls as having a community function, and that's really explicit in a lot of his writings in the 1940s and 1950s. And he wasn't alone in that. There are other early mall developers, including James Rouse, who comes back into the story later, who also built malls, you know, circa 1955, 1956, that had community spaces. They might have church spaces. They definitely had doctors' offices. A lot of malls also had nurseries. So these early malls had a lot more community functions built in, and they were thought of as replacing downtown. And so having these mixed use functions.
是的，格鲁恩绝对认为购物中心具有社区功能，这在他的 20 世纪 40 年代和 50 年代的许多著作中都非常明确。而且他不孤单。还有其他早期的购物中心开发商，包括詹姆斯·鲁斯（James Rouse），他后来也回到了这个故事中，他也建造了带有社区空间的购物中心（大约在 1955 年、1956 年左右）。它们可能设有教堂空间。它们绝对有医生办公室。许多购物中心还设有托儿所。因此，这些早期的购物中心内置了更多社区功能，它们被认为是对市中心的替代，因此具备了这些混合使用的功能。
But what happened was over time, by the mid-1960s, they're just start to be more and more malls, and they're not being designed and created by these original developers and the developers just want to make money. And they've also found that, you know, the mall has been kind of incorporated as an American pastime and it turns out you don't need to have a community space for your mall to operate like a community center. Like it's just doing that anyway. So, the mall is often blamed for killing downtowns, but is this completely fair? Like was the mall, you know, a reaction to filling a void that was already created by downtowns
但随着时间推移，到了 20 世纪 60 年代中期，购物中心开始越来越多，它们不再由最初的这些开发商设计和创建，开发商只想赚钱。他们还发现，购物中心已经被当作一种美国人的消遣方式融入了生活，事实证明，你的购物中心要像社区中心一样运作，其实并不需要刻意设置一个社区空间。无论如何，它自然而然就能做到这一点。因此，购物中心经常被指责为杀死市中心的罪魁祸首，但这完全公平吗？购物中心究竟是……
in the Klein or did they contribute in some way? The early malls were really predicated on investment by the department stores, but the department store owners only made that investment after they were already seeing a loss of business downtown. And the families who owned these department stores were frequently like major urban philanthropists. Like they were the ones who paid for new shows at the museum.
对填补市中心衰落所造成的真空的一种反应，还是它们在某种程度上推波助澜了？早期的购物中心确实是以百货公司的投资为前提的，但百货公司老板只有在看到市中心业务已经出现亏损后，才会做出这笔投资。而拥有这些百货公司的家族往往是主要的城市慈善家。比如他们是出资赞助博物馆新展览的人。
They were really like power players in Minneapolis, Detroit, Philadelphia, and these other cities. But as the suburbs expanded because the houses were built first, they began to draw all of this energy away from downtowns. And initially, and now it seems foolishly in retrospect, people thought the women would drive back into downtowns to shop during the day, either drive or take public transportation. But once women and children were kind of ensconced in their houses and the suburbs, that was just
他们确实是明尼阿波利斯、底特律、费城和其他这些城市的权力玩家。但随着郊区不断扩张——因为房子是先建好的——它们开始将所有这些活力从市中心抽离。最初，现在回想起来似乎很愚蠢，人们以为女性会为了白天购物而开车返回市中心，要么自己开车，要么坐公共交通。但一旦妇女和儿童在郊区安顿下来，那简直……
impossible. Like who would want to do that? And the shopping options were really limited because they were mostly these strip malls that had a supermarket in a drug store and maybe a kids shoe store. But they didn't have the kind of full service department store that they did downtown. So department store owners really wanted people to keep going downtown because that's where they had put all this time in investment. That was not an accurate read on human behavior. So very reluctantly department store owners began first to build
是不可能的。谁会想那样做呢？而且购物选择真的很有限，因为大部分都是一些露天广场，里面有一家超市、一家药店，可能还有一家童鞋店。但它们没有像市中心那样全方位的百货公司。所以百货公司的老板们真的很希望人们继续去市中心，因为那是他们投入了大量时间和投资的地方。这并不是对人类行为的准确解读。因此，百货公司老板们非常不情愿地开始首先建造……
some small free-standing stores. They called them, you know, them junior stores. And then, Grooan kind of came up with this way by packaging the department store with other stores that they could keep their sense of dignity. They really wanted their stores to still be glamorous and still be special and not just another thing by the highway. So the Grooan idea of the indoor shopping mall allowed them to keep some of that glamor from downtown and also feed off other shopping, but move out to the suburbs.
一些小型独立商店。他们称之为“初级商店”。然后，格鲁恩想出了一种方法，把百货公司与其他商店打包在一起，让他们能够保持尊严。他们真的很希望自己的商店依然光鲜亮丽、与众不同，而不仅仅是公路边的又一个普通建筑。因此，格鲁恩提出的室内购物中心理念让他们得以保留市中心的一部分魅力，同时借力其他商业形态，但又能搬到郊区去。
So these early malls go up, and they get a lot of attention, especially as one large mall designed by Victor Gruein in a dinam Minnesota called Southdale Center. And it's a big media story. But how are these early malls received by the architecture and design world at large? Like how did they respond? The architecture press was totally wowed by the early malls. Southdale in particular was treated
于是这些早期的购物中心拔地而起，吸引了大量关注，特别是明尼阿波利斯埃迪纳（Edina）一个由维克托·格鲁恩设计的名为绍斯代尔中心（Southdale Center）的大型购物中心。这是一个重大的媒体新闻。但是，当时的建筑和设计界对这些早期的购物中心作何反应？他们是如何回应的？建筑界媒体对早期的购物中心赞不绝口。特别是绍斯代尔被当作……
as this kind of second coming. One of the amazing things is that Jane Jacobs went out to a diner to see Southdale and wrote this like very glowing right up of it in architectural forums. And if you think about our stereotype of Jane Jacobs, she was all about the city, she was all about like small business. But at that moment, it was really seen as an important new element or important new tool for creating, you know, urbanism in
一种神圣的回归来对待。令人惊奇的事情之一是，简·雅各布斯（Jane Jacobs）曾专门跑到一家餐馆去参观绍斯代尔，并在《建筑论坛》上写了一篇高度赞扬的文章。如果你想想我们对简·雅各布斯的固有印象，她一向推崇城市，推崇小型商业。但在那个时刻，它确实被视为在郊区创造都市感的一个重要新元素或重要新工具。
the suburbs. The outside of shopping malls is really boring. They're just like the big gray boxes when you see them from the road. But all the design thinking goes into the inside of the mall with things like fountains and atramps. Why is that? I think that's where the community idea, this kind of utopian community idea from the gruin inception
购物中心的外观真的很无聊。当你从路上看去，它们就像是一个个巨大的灰色盒子。但所有的设计心思都花在了购物中心的内部，比如喷泉和中庭。这是为什么？我认为这正是社区理念的延续，即格鲁恩最初构想购物中心时那种乌托邦式的社区理念，因为如果你身处一个只会让你不得不拖着脚步往前走的空间里——比如机场航站楼——你根本不想多呆。但如果你身处一个拥有美丽的自然光、可能还有能让你的孩子往里扔硬币的喷泉，或者有长椅能让你在一家店逛到另一家店的间隙稍作休息的空间里……
of the mall really continues, because if you're in a space that just makes you want to shuffle along, like say, an airport terminal, you don't want to stay there. But if you're in a space where there's beautiful natural light, and maybe there's a fountain that your kids can throw pennies into, or maybe there's a bench so you can take a little break in between going from store to store,
你就会在那里待得更久。因此，即使购物中心的所有者不再为外观上的建筑特色花钱，他们仍然花大量时间投资于建筑特色。他们依然花大量时间投资于建筑特色以及对内部这些特色的维护。围绕购物中心的维护，存在着一整套话语体系。
you're going to stay there longer. And so even if mall owners stopped paying money for architectural features on the outside, they still spend a lot of time investing for architectural features on the outside. They still spend a lot of time investing in architectural features and the upkeep of those features on the inside. There's a whole dialogue around maintenance related to the mall.
我想如果你看一些废弃和垂死的购物中心的照片，你会发现第一批看到的现象之一就是植物枯萎了，或者花坛里的植物全被拔光了，再或者你知道的，垃圾桶不够用了。因此，购物中心迷人的魅力部分来自于这种美丽且维护精良的室内空间，无论什么时候去，那里的天气永远都是完美的。所以钱花在了这里，我认为一部分艺术性也投入到了这里。
And I think if you look at some pictures of dead and dying malls, like one of the first things you see is like the plants dying, or they've taken all of the plants out of the planters or you know there aren't enough trash cans anymore. And so part of the allure of the mall is of this like beautiful and beautifully maintained indoor space that you can go to at any time and the weather will always be perfect. And so like that's where the money goes and that's where I think some of the artistry
而且，我的书名就叫《在喷泉旁与我相遇》，因为这也是人们在购物中心里辨别方向的方式，对吧？比如：“在蓝色喷泉旁见”、“在红色喷泉旁见”。你知道的，购物中心可能是一个令人眼花缭乱、有点嘈杂的地方，但这些永久性的建筑特色能帮助我们辨别方向。在购物中心被引入并开始复制之后，我们迎来了 70 年代和 80 年代的购物中心建设热潮，然后它们真正开始改变美国的景观。你能聊聊那个时代以及巨型购物中心的崛起吗？
goes. And I mean, the title of my book is Meet Me by the Fountain because that's also how people orient themselves in malls, right? Like, Meet Me by the Blue Fountain, Meet Me by the Red Fountain. You know, the mall can be a confusing and kind of like, jangly place, but these perpetual architecture features help us orient ourselves. After the mall is introduced and it sort of like begins to replicate, then we hit the the building boom from malls in the 70s and 80s and and then they really began to change the landscape of America. Can you talk about that time and the sort of rise of the giant mall. The early malls a lot of times are really quite simple. It's just like that eye shape or a t-shape or a v-shape with like one or two or three department stores. And the reason you're going to the mall is to shop, to go to the
早期的购物中心很多时候其实相当简单。它只是一种眼睛形状、T 字形或 V 字形的设计，配备一两家或三家百货公司。你去购物中心的原因就是为了购物，去百货公司，或许顺便在小吃摊吃个快餐。美食广场直到 20 世纪 70 年代中期才真正成为购物中心的一部分。到了 20 世纪 80 年代，人们开始对购物中心产生第一波审美疲劳。人们对购物中心有点腻了。正是在这个时候，来自洛杉矶的建筑师约翰·杰瑞（John Jerde）登场了，他说：“好吧，我们怎样才能让人们重新想去购物中心呢？我知道了，我们在购物中心中间建一个游乐园。”一旦你在购物中心中间建了一个游乐园……
department store, to maybe get a snack and a snack bar. The food court doesn't actually become part of the mall until the mid 1970s. And then in the 1980s, you begin to get the first wave of boredom with the mall. Like people are kind of over the mall. And that's when John Jury comes in, this LA architect, and he's like, okay, how can we get people to want to go to the mall again? I know, we'll put an amusement park in the middle of the mall. And once you put an amusement park in the middle of the mall,
它的规模就会呈指数级扩大。是不是每个购物中心都以这种方式做出反应？我知道有一些标志性的购物中心，比如拥有过山车、水族馆之类设施的美国之梦购物中心（Mall of America）。这种效应是否扩散到了其他购物中心，还是仅仅局限于少数几个大型购物中心？在购物中心里建整个游乐园的做法实际上只局限于少数几个大型购物中心。但娱乐的理念确实扩散开了。
it gets exponentially bigger. And did every mall kind of react in this way? Like I know there's some key ones like Mall of America that has a roller coaster and a quarry and stuff like that. Did that effect kind of ripple out into other malls or was it really just confined to a few big ones? The entire amusement park in the mall is really confined to just a few large ones. But the entertainment idea does ripple out.
我的意思是，购物中心里的溜冰场越来越多了。美食广场规模越来越大，建筑风格也更具表现力，因此去美食广场本身成了一种活动，你可以品尝到越来越多不同种类的美食。购物中心里也开始增设游戏机厅。所以购物中心的供给变得越来越广泛，它们的营业面积也变得越来越大。这些购物中心对开发商而言也是一笔更大的投资。因此，它们正试图从更大、更广的区域吸引客源。如果说最初的购物中心只是为了服务周围的郊区和他们所在的城市象限……
I mean, you get more and more ice skating rinks in malls. You get bigger and bigger food courts and they get more expressive architecture so that like going to the food court is kind of an event and there are more and more Different kinds of cuisines that you can sample you also get our Cades added to malls So the offerings of malls get broader and broader and just their square footage gets bigger and bigger Those malls also like are a bigger investment for their developers. So they're trying to pull from a larger and larger area. So where's the original malls were really just trying to serve the suburbs all around them and like their quadrant of the city. These new malls are generally referred
那么这些新型购物中心通常被称为超区域购物中心。它们是人们真的会特意驱车前往的购物中心。当你要买毕业舞会礼服时，你和朋友们会坐上面包车，去一两个小时车程外的那家购物中心，因为那里有更大、更好的百货公司。你们会在那里待上一整天。这是一种完全不同的购物心态，它与购物中心本身的关系也略有不同。
to as super regional malls. So there are malls that people would really travel to. When you had to get your prom dress, you and your friends would like get in the minivan and go to the mall that was like one or two hours away because it had the bigger, better department stores. And you'd spend the whole day there. And it's just a different mentality about shopping and it's a slightly different relationship to the mall itself.
这里是圣安妮米斯购物中心（San Andy Miss Mall）。这就是当今世界人们闲逛的地方。上车，辣妹，我们要去购物了。我们去舞台吧。我和几个朋友去了购物中心。我有一大串糟糕的消费清单。你知道的，在 80 年代购物中心这种增长和全盛期以及某种文化上升期……
This is the San Andy Miss Mall. And this is where people of the days world hang out. Get in, Lizard, we're going shopping. Let's go to the stage. I went to the mall with a couple of friends. I had a whole list of lousy spin. You know, in the 80s during this growth and heyday of the sort of cultural ascendancies of malls,
人们对购物中心究竟是公共空间还是私人空间有着真正的、你知道的冲突。你能聊聊为什么这很重要，以及在购物中心内部发生的事情，与城市商业街区发生的事情有什么不同吗？正如你从整个购物中心的发展史中所能看出的那样，人们一直有一种渴望，试图将购物中心塑造成一个社区空间，进而将其塑造成一个公共空间，至少在短时间内假装……
there's a real, you know, conflict about the mall as a public space versus a private space. Can you talk about, you know, why that's important and what is happening inside of a mall that's different than what would happen if this was a shopping district in a city. As you can tell from the whole mall history, like there's been this desire to cast the mall as a community space and hence as a public space, to pretend at least for a minute
它是对所有人开放的，任何人随时都可以去那里。但随着购物中心变得越来越大，并真正开始充当那些事实上的公共空间时，你就会遇到这样一个事实：店主和购物中心业主其实并不希望在公共空间里可能发生的所有事情都在他们的购物中心里发生。其中最主要的、发生过的一项就是抗议活动。于是开始出现了一系列法庭案件，基本上在争论你是否可以在购物中心里抗议。最终成为州和联邦最高法院这些案件审理基础的抗议活动，涉及广泛的议题，其中一些是反战抗议……
that it's welcoming to everybody that anyone can go there at any time. But as the malls become bigger and actually start to serve as those de facto public spaces, you run up against the fact that store owners, mall owners don't really want all the things that can happen in a public space to happen in their mall. And the principal, one of those is protests. So there start to be this whole series of court cases basically arguing over whether you can protest in a mall. And the protests that end up serving as the basis for these cases in both like the state and federal Supreme Court are over a whole range of issues like some of them are anti-war protests, some of them are anti-war protests, some of them are anti-fur protests, some of them are union protests.
一些是反毛皮抗议，还有一些是工会抗议。但在每个案件中，购物中心业主都坚称他们有权将抗议者从他们的财产中驱逐出去，因为这不是公共财产，他们不必遵守言论自由规则。然后就会有律师辩称，如果购物中心要取代市中心，难道它们不也应该像市中心一样运作，允许任何想行使言论自由的人在这些物业中行使言论自由吗？
But in each case, the mall owner asserts that they have the right to eject the protesters from their property because they are not property, they don't have to follow free speech rules. And then you get attorneys arguing that if malls are going to be replaced downtowns, shouldn't they also have to operate like downtowns and let whoever wants to have free speech, have free speech and these properties.
1968 年最早的案件之一，瑟古德·马歇尔（Thurgood Marshall）来到美国最高法院并代表多数派进行辩论。其中有一段精彩的论述，他基本上谈到了购物中心是如何取代市中心的。我感到非常着迷的是，A，那是瑟古德·马歇尔；B，早在 1968 年的一项最高法院判决中，他就已经清晰地阐述了购物中心承担这种公共角色的方式。在那项裁决之后，法院变得越来越保守，购物中心中言论自由权的伸张实际上被不断侵蚀，直到它变成了一个各州的问题。现在，你知道的，这实际上成了由各州各自裁决的事情。最近在购物中心发生并演变成法庭案件的抗议活动之一，是圣诞节前夕在美利坚购物中心（Mall of America）爆发的“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）抗议活动。
One of the earliest cases in 1968, their good Marshall goes before the US Supreme Court and argues for the majority. And there's this great passage where he basically talks about how the mall has replaced downtown. And I was so fascinated to find that A, it was their good Marshall and B, that he had really articulated the way the malls had taken on this public role as early as 1968 in a Supreme Court opinion. After that decision, the court gets more and more conservative, and the assertion of free speech rights in malls actually gets eaten away until it becomes a state issue. And now, you know, that's something that's actually decided state by state. One of the most recent protests in malls that became a court case was a Black
在一年中最繁忙的购物周之一，美利坚购物中心陷入了与抗议者的法律斗争中。“黑人的命也是命”运动的四位领导人表示……
Lives Matter protest at the Mall of America right before Christmas. During one of the busiest shopping weeks of the year, the Mall of America has caught up in a legal battle with protesters. Four leaders of Black Lives Matter say they
他们在周五收到了信件。信中威胁称，如果周三的集会按计划在购物中心内部举行，他们将被捕。他们试图强迫我们去说一些……你知道的，他们其实并没有权力去说的话。这绝对不仅是对“黑人的命也是命”运动的攻击，也是对每个人第一修正案权利和发声权利的攻击。抗议者们一边高喊口号一边游行，而购物中心里围绕着所有这些圣诞树安装的屏幕都亮了起来，上面显示着抗议者不得不去面对的标语。
receive letters on Friday. Threatening arrests of Wednesday's rally takes place as planned inside the mall. They're trying to force us to say something that, you know, they don't really have the authority to do so. This is definitely not only an attack on Black Lives Matter, but on everybody's
以及购物中心里围绕着所有这些圣诞树安装的屏幕都亮了起来，上面显示着……
first amendment rights and the right to speak out. The protesters like marched in chanting and all of the screens that were installed in the mall around all of these Christmas trees lit up with messages that the protesters had to look at. and all of the screens that were installed in the mall around all of these Christmas trees lit up with messages
抗议者必须离开的标语。所以这有点像你在用抗议破坏圣诞节的商业展示。你必须思考：为什么“黑人的命也是命”的抗议者会选择美利坚购物中心？他们选择那里是因为那里有人。如果你不能让人们看到你……
that the protesters had to leave. So it was kind of like your ruining or like commercial display for Christmas with your protest. You have to think about like, why did the Black Lives Matter protesters choose the mall of the America? They chose it because there would be people there. Like there's no point in a protest if you're not going to have people see you,
支持你，并获得媒体报道，抗议就没有任何意义了。因此，像明尼阿波利斯这样寒冷的冬天，人流都集中在购物中心，这就是他们想在那里抗议的原因。我认为这才是所有这些法庭案件的核心症结所在。如果你把城市搬空，把所有的商业开发都放在郊区，你就必须在郊区留出空间来发生一些不只是出于商业动机的事情——即使这些事情并不合店主的胃口，也不是所有人都赞同的。并不是所有人都赞同。你可能已经注意到，我们已经度过了购物中心的鼎盛时期，随着全美各地的购物中心纷纷倒闭，我们将如何处理所有这些空置的空间？
enjoying you, and have media coverage. So in a place like Minneapolis, in the winter, the concentration of people were going to be at the mall, and that's why they wanted to protest there. And I think that's really the rub of all of these court cases. Like if you've evacuated your city and put all of your commercial development in the suburbs, you have to leave space in the suburbs for things to happen that aren't only commercially motivated, like aren't okay with store owners that everybody doesn't agree with. everybody doesn't agree with. You might have noticed that we're past the heyday of the mall, and with malls across America closing, what are we going to do with all that empty space?
购物中心的未来现在将何去何从？有多少购物中心已经倒闭？购物中心真的在消亡吗？具体的数据是怎样的？在它们的巅峰时期，全美大约有 2,000 个封闭式购物中心。我认为这个数字在过去 10 年里下降到了大约 1,500 个。人们预计大流行结束后，我们最终可能只剩下大约 800 个……
The future of the mall now? How many malls have closed and are malls actually dying off? Like what are the numbers like? At their peak, they were approximately like 2,000 enclosed malls in the US. I think that number went down to about 1500, over the past 10 years. And people are expecting us to end up like after the pandemic, probably around like 800
封闭式购物中心。在 20 世纪 90 年代——基本上是购物中心的巅峰时期——每年有 140 家新购物中心拔地而起。但在 2007 年，新建的购物中心数量为零。人们认为购物中心正在消亡并不是错的。确实将会出现一波巨大的倒闭潮。但我并不认为购物中心会彻底消失。我的意思是，800 个依然是一个相当大的数字。
and closed malls. In the 1990s, which was basically peak mall, there were 140 new malls being built per year. But in 2007, there were zero new malls that were built. People aren't wrong that the mall is dying. Like there is going to be this huge die off. But I don't think the mall is going away. I mean, 800 is still like a lot of malls.
其中许多确实是它们所在城镇的大型旗舰购物中心，比如在纽约地区，像费城郊外的普鲁士国王购物中心（King of Prussia）、新泽西州的肖特希尔斯购物中心（The Mall at Short Hills）或是扬克斯（Yonkers）的韦斯特切斯特购物中心（The Westchester）。因此，最富有的购物中心正在生存下来。真正正在消亡的，通常被称为 B 级和 C 级购物中心，它们可能曾拥有西尔斯（Sears）等已经倒闭的其他百货公司。
And many of those are really the big marquee malls in their towns, like in the New York area, it's things like King of Prussia, outside Philadelphia or the mall at Short Hills and New Jersey or the Westchester up in Yonkers. So the richest malls are surviving. It's really what are typically referred to as class B and C malls that might have had Sears and other department stores that have now gone out of business that are
所以这些正是人们拍摄令人沮丧的萧条景象的那些地方。它们也是进行适应性再利用的潜在场所。你认为导致购物中心倒闭的原因是什么？这是多种因素共同作用的结果。多年来，我们一直听到一种恐慌的说法，即在线零售将摧毁实体零售。而实际上，即使在今天，它也只占零售额的 21%。大流行加速了这一进程，因为更多人在网上购物，并发现它对很多事情来说都很棒。但仍有许多……
dying. And so those are the ones that people film like depressing glamour shots at. And also the ones that are potential sites for adaptive reuse. Why, what do you cite is the reason for malls closing? It's a whole bunch of things. We've had this kind of panicky story for years that online retail was going to destroy bricks and mortar retail. It's actually only 21% of retail sales even now. And the pandemic has accelerated that because more people were doing more internet shopping and found out that that can be great for a lot of things. But there are still many
种类的购物实际上更适合在线下当面进行。甚至在大流行之前，互联网购物也没有以最初可怕的预测所说的速度杀死实体零售。所以这是原因之一。此外，我们购物方式本身也发生了更大的变化。百货公司不再像过去那样扮演潮流风向标的角色。更多的人希望在较小的商店购物，即使这些商店不一定是独立经营的。除此之外，还有更大的收入差距。在购物中心崛起的时期，美国中产阶级发展良好且不断壮大。而现在，情况大不相同了，依然发展得很好的上中产阶级与资金越来越少的中下层和工人阶级之间存在着巨大的差距。这些家庭中的人们更有可能去大卖场和折扣店购物，因为他们实在没有收入去消费那些过去是购物中心经济支柱的中档商店。
kinds of shopping that are really better done in person. And even before the pandemic, internet shopping hadn't killed off bricks and mortar retail at the rate that initial dire predictions said it would. So that's part of it. There are also just like larger changes in the way we shop. Department stores are no longer the arbiters of taste that they used to be. And more people want to shop in smaller stores, even if those aren't necessarily independently owned. And then there's also just a greater income disparity. During the rise of the malls, the American middle class was doing well and growing. And now there is this great disparity between like the upper middle class that's still doing
这很有趣，因为今天有很多购物中心现在成了就业办公室和车管所（DMV）的所在地。
great and the lower middle and working class who have less and less money. And people in those families are much more likely to shop in big box stores and discount stores because they don't really have the income for kind of the middle range stores that used to be the bread and butter of the mall. It's funny because today there are lots of malls that are now home to employment offices and DMVs.
从某种意义上说，这超级酷，因为这正是更接近格鲁恩最初设计的混合使用理念。但你写道，当这种情况发生时，通常对购物中心来说是一个不好的信号，因为它们可能是因为极度渴望吸引人流，才给车管所提供便宜的租金。所以我的意思是，这有点讽刺。是的，我的意思是，这本该是一件好事。我认为在购物中心里设立车管所和其他公共服务机构会非常棒。
And in a way, that's super cool because that's the mixed-use idea that was closer to groom's original design of the mall. But you write that it's usually a bad sign for the mall when this happens because they probably give the DMV cheap rent because they're desperate to draw people in. So I mean, it's just kind of ironic. Yeah, I mean, that should be a good thing. I think having a DMV and other public services inside a mall would be great.
想想看，如果你在周末时间有限，能把所有这些事情都办妥，那该有多方便。事实上，在我的书的结语中，我谈到了其他一些国家的购物中心，包括菲律宾，那里的许多购物中心理所当然地将许多公共服务融入其中。我母亲是达勒姆公共图书馆之友的志愿者，他们经营着……
Like, think how convenient that would be if you have limited time on a weekend, you can get all of these things taken care of. And in fact, in the conclusion of my book, I talk about the malls in some other countries, including the Philippines, where many of the malls have a lot of public services, you know, just folded into them as a matter of course. My mother volunteers for the Friends of the Durham Public Library and they run
一家二手书店，它曾是达勒姆北门购物中心在倒闭前某个空置店面里的商家之一。所以再次证明，当商业企业不再愿意支付租金时，城市服务便进驻了。对于购物中心来说，除非有其他大型业态进驻，否则很难从主力百货公司的倒闭中恢复过来。苦苦挣扎的购物中心有什么办法能恢复生机吗？有没有一种切实有效的公式？有些购物中心通过引入蹦床乐园之类的地方得到了拯救，或者至少实现了稳定。同样的，这也是娱乐场所。我认为未来购物中心能够生存下去的方法之一，是对购物中心的商店进行更聪明、或许也更独特的策划。我的意思是，我知道“策划”这个词有点被用滥了，但我想长期以来，购物中心之所以能维持下去，基本上是因为它们都有着相同的商店和餐厅组合……
a used bookstore and it was one of the businesses in an empty storefront in Northgate Mall in Durham before it closed. So again, city services come in where commercial businesses don't want to pay rent anymore. It's hard for malls to recover from one of their anchor department stores clothing unless something else big comes in. Is there a way for struggling malls to recover? Is there a formula that that actually works? Some malls have been saved or at least stabilized by things like trampoline parks coming in. Again, like that's the entertainment venue. One of the ways that I think malls can survive in the future is through smarter and perhaps more distinct curation of the mall stores. I mean, you know, I know that curation is kind of an overused term, but I think for a long time malls are getting by on essentially all having the same mix of stores
只是价格点不同罢了。所以你基本上只需要决定那天你想花多少钱，然后去相应的购物中心就行了。但在未来，在网上买到便宜的连锁店服装已经足够容易了。因此，购物中心可以通过储备专为家庭服务的东西来真正让自己脱颖而出。或者我在书中有几个例子，购物中心基本上把自己变成了民族美食和商业中心，这取决于它们郊区不断变化的人口构成。所以你会有亚特兰大郊外的拉丁裔购物中心……
and restaurants, just a different price point. So you'd kind of, you know, decide how much money you wanted to spend that day and go to that mall. But going forward, it's easy enough to get, you know, inexpensive chain store clothing online. So, malls could really distinguish themselves by stocking themselves with things that are all for families. Or I have a couple examples in the book where malls have turned themselves essentially into like ethnic food and business centers, depending on like the changing nature of their suburb. So you have like a Latino mall outside Atlanta
或者是北加州的许多亚洲购物中心，里面有来自其他地方的人们熟悉的企业，但也是他们在其他地方买不到的，并且出售他们在网上买不到的东西。当购物中心真的失败并倒闭时，会有成千上万平方英尺的空间闲置。但在它们消失之后，并没有太多适合购物中心这种体量的事情可以塞进去。这些废弃的购物中心最后都怎么了？嗯，很多时候它们就在那里闲置相当长一段时间，因为不仅有这成千上万平方英尺的空间是许多实体无法处理的……
or a lot of Asian malls in Northern California that have businesses that are familiar to people from other places, but also that they can't get somewhere else, and which sell things that they can't get online. When malls do fail and they do close, there's like thousands and thousands of square feet going unused. But there aren't a lot of mall shaped things that you can put in there after one is gone. What happens with these dead malls? Well, a lot of times they just sit there for quite some time because not only do they have these many thousands of square feet that not a lot of entities can deal with,
而且它们通常由多个实体拥有。所以这并不像一个人把购物中心卖给另一个人那么简单。有一些进行适应性再利用的案例，即新企业或其他机构接管了一个废弃的购物中心。你见过最有趣的例子是什么？德克萨斯州奥斯汀郊外的海兰购物中心（Highland Mall）在过去十多年里被改造成了奥斯汀社区学院（Austin Community College）的领导力校区。他们把其中一家前百货公司变成了一个巨大的电脑室般的车间空间。他们还把另一家百货公司……
but often they're owned by multiple entities. And so it's not as easy as just like one person selling the mall to one other person. There have been some cases of adaptive reuse where a new business or something is taken over a dead mall. What is the most interesting example of that that you've seen? Highland mall outside Austin, Texas has been turned over the past decade plus into the leadership campus for Austin Community College. And they turned one of the former department stores into like this huge like room full of computers, like workshops face. And they have turned one of the other department stores
变成了奥斯汀公共电视台（Austin Public TV）的总部，里面有大量的内部工作室、录音空间和一个礼堂。购物中心周围的停车场，他们实际上把其中一部分改造成了绿色的开放空间，有点像普通的大学校园。在周边地区，他们正在建造住房，其中一些可以作为学生宿舍，而另一些则可以作为……
into the headquarters for Austin Public TV with a lot of internal studio and recording space and an auditorium. And the parking lot around the mall, some of it they've actually made green open spaces sort of like a regular college campus. And around the perimeter they're building housing, some of like a regular college campus, and around the perimeter they're building housing, some of which can be student housing, but other of which can just be, you
你知道的，经济实惠的出租公寓。如果我们能以某种方式重复利用这些废弃的购物中心，那就太棒了。人们总是说最环保的建筑就是已经建造好的建筑。当谈到重复利用购物中心时，你有什么感受？我很高兴看到这些适应性再利用的例子。当人们谈论适应性再利用时，他们往往想到的是城市里的老建筑，但到了这个阶段，购物中心本身也已经成了老建筑。
know, affordable rental apartments. It's great if we could reuse these dead malls in some way. Like people always say that the green is building as a building that's already built. How do you feel about it when it comes to reusing malls? I love to see these examples of adaptive reuse. Like, when people talk about adaptive reuse, they're often thinking about older buildings in cities, but at this point, malls are older buildings.
你知道的，价格实惠的出租公寓。如果我们能以某种方式重新利用这些死气沉沉的购物中心，那就太棒了。就像人们常说的那样，最环保的建筑就是已经建好的建筑。在重新利用购物中心这件事上，你有什么看法？我非常喜欢看到这些适应性再利用的例子。比如，当人们谈论适应性再利用时，他们通常会想到城市里的老建筑，但就目前而言，购物中心也已经是老建筑了。
I mean, like, many of the malls that we're talking about that are failing are 50 years old. And I was actually talking to the chancellor of Austin Community College. And he was saying that lots of people have very poignant family memories of things that happened in the food court at that mall. These buildings aren't just buildings in their communities.
我的意思是，我们谈论的许多正在没落的商场都已经有50年的历史了。我实际上和奥斯汀社区学院的校长交谈过。他说，许多人对那个商场美食广场发生的事情有着非常深刻的家庭记忆。这些建筑不仅仅是他们社区里的建筑物。
They're a, they're very conveniently located, b, like everyone knows where Highland Mall is because it's been a reference point. And we shouldn't just kind of throw away those memories and throw away that kind of name recognition along with like getting rid of the tremendous like environmental sync of the building materials. So I really see the malls as an opportunity and I would love for people to get more creative about what to do with them. There's a lot of like dead mall photography,
它们，a，地理位置非常便利，b，就像每个人都知道海兰德购物中心在哪里一样，因为它一直是一个地标。我们不应该就这样抛弃这些记忆，抛弃那种知名度，同时还要摆脱建筑材料巨大的环境负荷。所以我真的把商场看作是一个机遇，我希望人们能对如何处理它们有更多的创意。有很多关于荒废商场的摄影作品，
which I think can be very beautiful, but it also kind of fixes them in people's minds as these dead entities. And I think kind of like them in people's minds as these dead entities. And I think kind of like stops the mental process that it takes to then think of, okay, what are we going to do with it next? And I mean, I guess coming from a design background, I just see them as an opportunity and a problem and something that could be really fun to think about. And you know, something that shouldn't be depressing, but it's like,
我认为这些照片可以非常美丽，但它也在人们的心中将它们定格为这些死去的实体。我认为这有点像在人们心中将它们视为死物，并阻止了人们去思考“好吧，我们接下来要拿它怎么办？”的心理过程。我的意思是，从设计背景出身，我只是把它们看作是一个机遇、一个问题，以及一件思考起来会非常有趣的事情。你知道，这不应该是一件令人沮丧的事，而是像，
oh, actually, there's all this new free land in cities. Like, what can we do with it? Well, this has been so great. I've really enjoyed the book, too. It was just so much fun to both learn a lot of stuff and also have all this information slot into my own sort of lived experience of a mall, I appreciate it. Thanks for having me.
哦，事实上，城市里有这么多新出现的空闲土地。比如，我们能用它做点什么？嗯，这次访谈太棒了。我也非常喜欢这本书。既能学到很多东西，又能将所有这些信息融入到我自己对商场的亲身经历中，真的很有趣，我很感激。谢谢你邀请我。
Alexander Leng's book is called Meet Me by the Found and Inside History of the Mall. And if you buy the book, which I highly recommend and you flip it over and you look at the back cover, you will find that someone is written. It's an architectural page-turner. This insightful, witty and smart book captures everything compelling and confounding about the American Mall. Roman Mars, co-author of the 99% of this book,
亚历山大·伦的这本书叫做《在喷泉旁见：商场的内幕历史》。如果你买这本书——我强烈推荐你买——然后把它翻过来看看封底，你会发现有人写道：“这是一本引人入胜的建筑读物。这本深刻、风趣且聪明的书捕捉到了美国商场所有引人入胜且令人困惑的特质。”罗曼·马尔斯，《99%无形》这本书的合著者，
I wrote that for the back of this book. That's how much I believe in this book. You should get it. 99% of this book was produced this week by Chris Barube, music by a director of sound Swan Rio, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, fact checking by Liz Boyd. Our executive producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstad is our digital director, our intern is Sarah Beak. The rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Jason Delion, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald,
这话是我为这本书的封底写的。可见我对这本书有多么深信不疑。你应该买一本。《99%无形》这期节目本周由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里奥创作，混音和技术制作由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，事实核查由莉兹·博伊德负责。我们的执行制片人是德兰妮·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监，我们的实习生是莎拉·比克。团队的其他成员包括薇薇安·李、杰森·德利翁、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、
Lashemadon, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious XM Podcast family. Now head towards six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars
拉谢马顿、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客大家庭的一部分。现在前往位于美丽繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心潘多拉大厦以北六个街区的地方。您可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars
and the show at 99PI Ork, on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Mars and the show at 99PIorg. One Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Get in loser, we're going Stitcher. Get in loser, we're going Stitcher. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及节目@99PI Ork，在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也可以。您可以在 99PI.org 上找到其他我喜欢的 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。上车吧，失败者，我们要去 Stitcher 了。上车吧，失败者，我们要去 Stitcher 了。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。